[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
45 hard to believe it's number 45
already with time standing still how
have we done
so many live streams boy it is hard to
imagine
it is hard to imagine i found myself
tweeting about
where we were in history and claiming
that it was still
august even though we were nearly
halfway through september at the time
but i'm not embarrassed i'm just i'm i'm
going with it
yeah i feel like our particular
situation here
and personalities and living situation
allowed us to get through lockdown which
is still persisting
with a fair bit of grace
but the effective lockdowns that the
fires have
um have caused now in the pacific
northwest
uh are actually really doing a number on
both of us
uh being actually forced to stay inside
and still having air quality inside
begin to decay
because no building is is completely
smoke proof
is well it's actually it's exhausting on
top of everything else
it's actually tiring to to feel this
kind of trapped
yeah it's uh it's both physically tiring
i have a feeling that you know
i feel i'm doing better with the smoke
than i would have expected but it's
it's beginning to uh be physically tough
to just deal with it day after day
yeah um but also you and i have
obviously been
um talking about the fact that we were
lucky to be
locked down as the weather was getting
nicer and the days were getting longer
and we were fearing what would happen
when
winter drove people indoors and the
fires have
created a little taste of what that will
be like and i must say
it really does increase the challenge so
much
because yeah the loophole in kovid was
that outdoor was
was safe well this is i mean this is i
think
worse um because going outside you're
even when you're masked and you know we
don't we don't have surgical masks so it
might be better if you actually had an
n95 but
um your lungs and sinuses start to hurt
pretty quickly at this level of smoke at
least
at least for us and so you know one of
the beautiful things about the pacific
northwest
is uh that basically you can dress for
almost any weather condition and go out
in it and
most of those weather conditions won't
be your preferred weather condition but
you can you can deal with it and this
this actually just doesn't allow for
that you know we have
i have saw something about one of my
weather apps today that i actually
hadn't seen before i've seen dense fog
advisories
uh we've had now for days apparently a
dense smoke advisory
um we've got um our wildfire evacuation
zone here in portland is getting
downgraded um which is to say that the
the areas in clackamas county that
are um in these sort of get ready to
evacuate zones are receding
somewhat but the fires are still
completely uncontained
uh and the rain the promised rain didn't
come and hopefully it will come soon but
it sort of it feels like this this
endless
endless awfulness uh the difference
between this and early covet lockdown is
you look out the window and you see
uh sort of this yellow toxicity in the
air
yeah i looked at um the weather app
uh dark sky and it said uh
winter is coming and full of terrors
which i thought suggested a not too
careful reading
of game of thrones at the very least
yeah absolutely um
but yeah it's really it's really tough
and it's day after day it really has
taken um even the strange way that time
was proceeding
before the fires and seemingly grounded
to a halt just it constantly looks the
same out the window and very bleak
yeah um yeah so for those of you not in
the pacific northwest
congratulations good on you and for
those of you who are i expect you know
exactly what we're talking about this is
this is different from anything i've
experienced before i did want to start
today by just doing a little follow-up
on
you know we spent almost all of last
episode talking about the fires
and the human history with fires in the
american west's history with fires
um and i wanted to do a little follow-up
on that and a little follow-up on the
other thing we talked about in the last
episode which was the
um uh netflix distributed film cuties
okay
and then and then get into all sorts of
other stuff including i promise we're
going to talk about uh virgin birth and
snakes before the end of the hour
i mean because when don't we i i tend to
yeah um okay so
um let's see one thing i wanted to say
is that the lead author on one of the
papers we talked about last time
um which found let me pull this up
which oh this is the paper that looked
at uh fire climate interactions the
american west
for the last over 600 years uh and
um was doing this you know very nuanced
careful analysis
um of the factors um and the
the factors leading to um the particular
moments of high fire activity
has now published um a really good op
ed um the woman's name is valerie true
it's true i did not look up how to
pronounce it zach you could show this
just briefly
uh in the guardian and you know the
guardian is uh as woke on the other side
of the pond as the new york times
um is on this side of the pond by a lot
but this is um
this is this is quite a good op-ed and i
think you know
because because this researcher um she
is i think she's a
dendrochronologist so her background is
specifically in
looking at tree rings and assessing um
not just age but sort of you know
climatic and weather events from tree
rings
um she she argues
here as she did with her co-authors in
this 2010 paper and is presumably many
times since
as we did in our last episode against
the 20th century regime of fire
suppression in the american west
and for uh what we were calling
following
uh i believe it was like a 1991 paper or
something pyro diversity
which i just kind of liked the term and
so when i keep saying it the idea being
that more types of smaller
more heterogeneous fires in the american
west and presumably anywhere where there
is a normally recurring fire regime
will actually increase lots of things
around ecosystem health but specifically
the measure that
i found evidence for was biodiversity i
i am not buying this pyro diversity
thing at all
right not falling for at this time i'm
going for pyro equity that's what i want
to see oh no
yes so all fires have equal outcomes is
that what we're shooting for
no i don't i think it's more like the
burning of white people i don't know but
something good
and the conversation grinds to a halt
you're only minutes in
only minutes in yeah so one of the
things she says in this uh
in this very good op-ed in the guardian
is we can't reverse the anthropogenic
heat and forest drought situation that
we have created by which he's referring
to
climate change that portion of the
increased fires in the american west
that are attributable to climate
change she says we cannot reverse that
situation at least in the short term
but we can aim to reverse the effects of
our century-long fire deficit
and so this i mean i think this is
exactly the kind of analysis that we
need we're not
she's not pretending um that long
term uh we don't have the ability to
nor do we have nor do we and we have the
need to
actually address uh the anthropogenic
anthropogenic climate change
um the 30 to 50 by the numbers that i
was finding and reporting on last time
um of the increased fires in the west
that attributable to anthropogenic
climate change but there's an
awful lot left that needs to be
explained and some of it is
there will always be fires and um but
you know a fire if all fires are not
created equally of course
and so um the sheer the rapidity
of the spread of these fires and the
absolute uh you know terrifying damage
and death that they have brought
is not a normal feature of an american
west burning as far as we can tell
either in modern times or from like tree
rang and pollen core studies
so um there are a number of ways to look
at this one i would say
i saw this article i also saw there was
one in propublica
earlier this week um with the title
something like given that we know how to
stop these fires
why don't we yeah and i read it
and it mirrored almost exactly the
perspective that we
advanced off the cuff on our last live
stream which was
you know reassuring um it did
it was off the cuff for you but i had
done some preparation you had done some
preparation
um but in any case um
the problem here is that we are again
wandering into a politicized landscape
which makes it impossible to do what
needs to be done right so at some level
we're looking for an analysis that says
something like the following
we have an entirely anthropogenic
problem
some of that anthropogenic problem can
be addressed
with solutions that we have and some of
it is now outside of our control
to the extent that we have altered the
climate that is not something that we
have the technology to unalter at the
moment
to the extent that we have altered the
fuel load
through a naive pattern of fire
suppression we do have the ability to
address this and again as i said in our
last live stream
the key question is one of equilibrium
yes
if you think about the fuel that
ends up accumulating if you prevent fuel
from burning off it accumulates
on the forest floor or as as you know
decaying biomass and then when a fire
does come
it's hotter and bigger than it would
otherwise be it may take out species
that are otherwise built to deal
with fire and so the real question is
how much stuff
has built up ready to burn and if you
are removing one of the processes that
eliminates that stuff then you will have
a disproportionately
large amount of it which will cause an
ecologically unusual phenomenon so
you have to get back to equilibrium
somehow or you have to set an
equilibrium that you now know how to
manage
there's no two ways about this yeah now
i agree with this the only
the only issue i would take with what
you just said is that you led with
we have an entirely anthropogenic
problem and i'm not sure
by what analysis you arrive there you
know the the west
the west coast of north america unlike
the east coast for instance
tends to burn regularly um even absent
modern levels of population density
industrialization and agriculture
and um and it seems even before there
were people you know
the pre-columbian people the first
americans were here
um setting regular fires to do a kind of
a landscape management you know we have
pollen cores going back
if memory serves from the last
livestream like 200 000 years
and there have been regular fires this
is exactly what i'm saying
but so in what so obviously fire in the
american west is not entirely an
anti-anthropogenic
the problem is that the disaster is
anthropogenic
fire is natural and the point is what
does fire look like under normal
circumstances
well it looks like a pattern in which
you get
chaotic sparking from lightning
primarily that results in
places that have accumulated more fuel
being more likely to catch fire
and then it's spreading to a point and
burning out
and is it that california would catch
fire no
it's never been that way pieces of
california will catch fire
while others have so recently caught
fire that they're not vulnerable anymore
and so what you get is a natural
patchwork dynamic in which the ecosystem
the species that are
are in the location are adapted to the
fire regime because the fire regime has
existed for millions of years
everything functions this way you walk
in it can't be exactly like that
anymore but the the naive thing is to
assume
that you can just simply intervene and
bend it to your will
and the answer is nature bats last right
it has the capacity to you know yes you
can suppress fire for
100 years and then what happens then you
have these mega fires that you can't
manage right
so what we need to do is
recognize that the wise approach is the
one
that disrupts the regime that functions
as little
as possible which doesn't mean zero but
the
the propublica article mentioned all of
the stuff we talked about it mentioned
the fact that sprawl is causing a
problem the fuel load is causing a
problem and i should say the president
um said something crazy about trees
exploding which he got
dragged for on twitter but in some sense
what he was struggling to articulate was
this point about fuel
buildup trees exploding okay well he
said something crazy and
you know true to form it was sort of off
the cuff
nonsense but i think i'm going to remain
blissfully unaware of the specifics
perfect well anyway uh what he was
talking about was the accumulation of
fuel and its impact on fire regimes and
so the point is
you know everybody's aware of this
problem yeah at what point are we gonna
modernize our
approach yeah all right well one more
thing to say about fires
um to follow up from last time is
um is an observation from
some some zoom earth
real-time satellite images zach if you
would show the screen
um this is uh this was sent to us
by a listener with um
considerable background in uh this kind
of
um in this kind of analysis
and said just take a look this person
said
just take a look at what the fires uh in
the pacific northwest specifically in
oregon look like from the beginning of
september
and so uh without saying anything more
about them just going to move through
september first
all the little red things are you know
fires obviously and we've got cloud
cover
second third fourth
fifth sixth seventh
eighth oof ninth
tenth 11th 12th now we've got
um smoke as well as the atmospheric
stuff
um 13th 14th
15th and that gets us to today um so
let me just go back to the seventh where
for those
uh listening only and not watching you
see some
fires um scattered throughout the
pacific northwest
um in eastern washington looks like like
the okanagan
in east central
oregon a few little ones in oregon and
some certainly up in sort of trinity
alps area
and such in northern california and then
you go one day forward and suddenly
we've got a tremendous number of fires
and
um you know roads aren't on here but to
anyone familiar with pacific northwest
that looks like a line of fires along
the five
along the interstate five to me and
um i'm not saying that is what it is
um i have not mapped this on to the five
uh nor can we say at this point for sure
what exactly is going on
um but we know we know for sure
that at least some of the fires that
have been
um that have been happening the pacific
northwest in the last couple of weeks
uh we're arson we're human set we're
intentional
and the fact that you have a sudden
upsurge in the fires all along a line
that is easy to access
on one day is certainly suspicious
and what we see is what looks like sort
of a knee-jerk rejection of the idea
that any of the fires are arson from the
official sources
at least in the state of oregon which
you know given
how busy everyone is right now the idea
that um
effective analysis has already been done
and they can completely rule out arson
for any of these strikes
me as itself an indicator that um
perhaps something is being covered up
so let's just uh do this correctly
there are processes that could associate
fires with roads that have nothing to do
with arson for example
people sometimes pull a car onto a
median that has
grass and the hot uh exhaust absolutely
the car can catch stuff on fire it's
usually completely obvious when this has
happened
in general these things you know catch
grasslands on fire and they're quickly
put out but not always
um and there was a severe wind event
that was happening there was a
severe wind event there are of course
you know
people find patterns and of course it
could be that you know the pattern was
the wind
regime which dried things out and then
uh
you know a lot of cars that broke down
and got
got the grass hot under them and set
fires that otherwise wouldn't have
wouldn't have become raging infernos yep
or sparks that would
not have ordinarily triggered uh fires
might under those unusual conditions
from many sources of produced fires
could be accidents i mean people don't
fling cigarette butts out the window the
way they once did from their cars but
things like that
so there's lots of stuff that could
create a pattern including it could be
random and look like a pattern to us
um you know because sometimes random
points line
up on the other hand what i think we do
know
is and i'm you know i thought a little
bit about your term knee-jerk
rejection of the idea that these fires
were intentionally set and i'm
i've gone both ways on it and thinking
about it i think what we have
is an environment in which the
claim that a fire started with arson
is now a political claim that's right
and because it is a political
claim this isn't even um
knee-jerk suggesting uninvestigated this
is
an automatic tribesmanship it's snatches
it's tribal
and the problem is you can't run
a society this way you cannot have a
disagreement over
facts because the facts point in an
inconvenient political direction
and of course we've seen this many times
you've seen it with climate change and
other such things and you know very
frequently people like you and me who
reason from
first principles and try to do so you
know
soberly with a scientific background are
often caught
in between the two camps right you and i
fall out
in the anthropogenic climate change camp
but
we're no fan of the models that are
usually used to defend this position
right so and you know there's or the
uh you know where scientists trust us do
what we
say because we're wearing the right
clothes and have the right degrees
approach which is itself of course uh
you know leading by authority which
is a just a step away from authoritarian
approach which is anti-scientific
right and so at some level the
we are staring at the collapse of
civilization
from no cause greater you don't need
anything more
than the simple agreement to take the
facts
and capture them for your side that's
sufficient because that will collapse
medicine it will it will cause economics
to
fall apart or to serve one side at the
expense of another there
you cannot have a situation in which we
can't at least agree on what took place
before we get around to arguing what to
make of it
and the idea that we are living in a
state in which
fires are raging out of control health
is
severely compromised and
there is any possibility that we would
even have to worry
that we were being protected from the
information that fires were the result
of arson
is uh already evidence that we are in a
just a dire scenario yeah that's right
even if they're not arson we want to
know that that
that idea has been fully vetted before
it's been rejected and we know
that in some cases it's unambiguous
right we can see on twitter evidence of
fireworks associated with certain fires
where citizens put them out
so yeah man how did we end up here
well yeah that's some of what we're
trying to talk about and figure out
isn't it but uh let's
let's pivot if if we can because there's
a lot of stuff not related to what we
talked about in the last episode that we
want to talk about but
i did want to spend a moment um
returning to
this this cuties film which we watched
the night before our last
livestream and we talked about it and we
are not fans
um afterwards i watched
a excellent many viewers will be
familiar with it an
excellent six minute um sack if you just
show the super
super briefly and then take it off um
let's see let me take it back to the
beginning you weren't quite there so
this is um okay you can take it off now
so that i can talk again
um this is a six minute video interview
with the writer director of cuties
uh mamuna do corey i think is how uh she
was pronouncing her name
um and it's really exquisite
like she she compels me that as you were
arguing in our discussion of the film
um that the message is not that the
message that she was trying to
convey is not that this hypersexualizing
of um pre-teen girls
is an apt response to the disempowerment
and desexualization
of a traditional islamic household um
that that is that is not an honorable
thing she finds she finds problems in
both approaches
um and you know as i said then it's it's
no more empowering of women
uh to do what is being uh depicted in
this film
than um to have to hide under a under
a burqa uh your entire adult life um
but so i was compelled by her she's
she's a you know clearly an
extremely smart beautiful woman with um
who's pulling
a lot of what she's talking about in
this film from what she's seen in her
own life and she interviewed a lot of
pre-teen girls
herself um in paris immigrants from
senegal
uh and so you know that all suggests
that this this work had a lot of work
behind it this art had a lot of work
behind it but
um but she doesn't achieve what she
tried to do
and the ends don't justify the means so
i i wanted to say you know
i recommend watching her six minute
video interview
while i don't recommend watching the
film um
and it reminded me i've seen people
defending
um the film i've seen a lot of people
rejecting the film on social media and i
suspect that they haven't seen it
i've similarly seen a lot of people
defending the film on social media and i
sort of suspect that many of them
haven't seen it
and i i suspect actually that if you'd
seen the six minute video
um as opposed to the clip of the girls
twerking
and that was all you had seen you would
find it very easy to get slide into one
of these positions or the other
and that frankly the sort of
intelligentsia on the left
is much more likely to be compelled by
this
you know beautiful and eloquent and
smart filmmaker um speaking for six
minutes about her intentions
than other people might be so i was
reminded of um
actually just my first first two years
in college when i was a literature major
before i ran away
precisely because of the kinds of
conversations that were happening that
they were that there was just no way to
assess the validity
um of the narratives that were being put
forward to explain what we were reading
in these
um clearly fictional um narratives um
so the discussions this would have been
back in the late 80s surrounded around
whether or not we should assess art on
its own
or if we needed to include an awareness
and analysis of the creator
and his or her intentions in the art uh
and broadly speaking this is
a sort of a brand of theory called
historical biographical criticism and it
is a critical method that
um and here i'm quoting wikipedia the
excellent source um
that um historical biographical
criticism is a critical method that sees
a literary work chiefly
if not exclusively as a reflection of
its author's life and times
that is you cannot be expected to
actually take the art and assess the art
on its own you have to wrap it up in all
of its context
um and to that i would say i'm often
most people are often interested in the
backstory
of the creator of a piece of work or to
read an artist's statement if it's
available right
but it shouldn't and it can't be
critical to interpreting the art the art
must stand on its own
and the idea that especially when we
have a piece of art that is actually
um that looks like this the idea that
you have to include
the intentions of the creator in your
assessment of whether or not
it's it's an honorable thing to be out
there i think is
exactly wrong so i've seen it argued um
that there was no intention um that this
was sexually exploitative
um and therefore it's not right um and i
i don't buy that now i don't
neither of us are calling this porn so
we don't have to go there um
but we we did and we are calling it
sexual
sexual exploitation of pre-teen girls
both of the actresses
and potentially leading to more of the
same by people watching it
and uh the fact that the intention might
have been in fact the opposite
by the creator doesn't actually change
the fact of the art itself um
well i'm not a hundred percent convinced
that the background of the maker can
never be
required for the art to be interpreted
so i'm just imagining
that there's certain things um
there's certain things that require
standing
in other words if a holocaust survivor
wants to
make a peace in which they humanize
a guard in a concentration camp
that's very different than if some
person with no connection
decides to do it and so i'm not saying
that the art shouldn't be able to stand
on its own
but i'm saying that in that case the
context might allow me
to engage the art openly it might it
might allow a window into it it might
allow you to approach it in a way that
you would not otherwise choose to
approach it and
i think that's that sounds completely
valid to me
i guess in this case i worry that this
will do that job
oh right that this you know that you
know we did watch it we did not
speak publicly about it before we had
actually seen the film
and uh you know in many ways it was you
know
beautifully done but but the girls
are heavily sexualized and
you know if even if it's only those four
child actors right
even if that's the only effect um it's
it's too
much it's too much and you know your
point last last episode was
if this were a book that would be a
different situation right because you
could explore something without anybody
being hurt yeah right
now in this case i think if we're you
know now that we know
that you know based on your viewing of
this
six minute uh piece that
my interpretation of that last scene
which is too brief
to make its point is actually the right
one that actually she's
judging both these things both the
overly restrictive
um you know muslim upbringing and the
overly
um liberated which isn't even the right
word but sexualized
um western alternative she's judging
both of them which i actually think is a
very important point but
what happened here is a perfectly
predictable western tragedy
which is that this person who has
standing sees a problem delivers
a film and it is two things happen one
it is co-opted by a very western entity
netflix right which sees this as a much
as a very saleable property precisely
for the
you know it invalidates half of the
filmmaker's point
in order to sell this thing this is this
is a small art form
it's not that netflix distributing it
was was a fail that was potentially a
huge win but allowing them to do the
marketing once they
had signed onto the distributing um
clearly did indicate exactly the fail
that you're talking about right and
frankly i think the only reason that
netflix gives a [ __ ] about this film
which they clearly did was that they
could use it
for for an ironic purpose which was to
capture an awful lot of attention either
because of the controversy
or because uh they had these sexualized
girls you know and that that should sell
even though it shouldn't sell right
so um netflix what it did
is despicable it creates
a lens through which most people arrive
at the film which will cause them to get
the wrong message out of it which will
cause you know so
it distorts the film and
um the other thing which i think is even
more frightening
is that because we live in a culture
that is
constantly pushing uh
youthful female sexuality to sell
everything
right because that's the lens that is
being imposed on society by
marketers um and presumably people who
sell porn
right that lens means that this film
which is supposed to
repulse you with the sexualization of
these young girls
doesn't work that way for the whole
audience there's some fraction of the
audience
that finds it positive and therefore
gets entirely the wrong message from the
film
so um you know that is uh it's an
incredibly
revealing phenomenon that this film has
created i mean
you know in addition to the phenomenon
that you point out which is that anyone
and everyone
uh considers themselves an expert on
this film whether or not they've seen
anything beyond the poster
right right so um yeah this
uh one way or the other this film seems
to reveal a tremendous number of
failings in our system and uh that's
right
you know what to do about it is a
question but
obviously the market didn't solve
problems here the market
created many problems yes yes
all right well um lots of other places
to go
we could uh we could rip the new york
times to shreds
oh my god do you mean physically or i
didn't bring it no
no i just have to be with words let's do
it metaphorically you want to start
there why not
okay so let's see if i can
pull this up hold on where did it go
okay zach would you show this this is
from
uh this is from the sunday
this last sunday's new york times the
front page very front page
um september 13th 2020 has this graphic
for those of you who are listening
not watching um biden stays ahead joe
biden is leading among likely voters in
four swing states including one donald
trump narrowly won in 2016.
and it would appear to be a simple
graphic it would appear to be
deeply quantitative wouldn't it just
like looks like numbers and therefore
you can trust them
because once it's numbers once it's been
counted it's got the stamp of authority
on it
so what we have is the results of a poll
from september 2020
and in four states with biden leading in
all of them
and we are the new york times is
comparing that to
the results from 2016
in which um
in which well it doesn't even matter in
which
sorry i got distracted they're looking
at these these numbers um as one does
um that is not the comparison that this
calls for
in what world does it make sense
actually to compare the results of a
poll in september 2020
to the actual election results following
the 2016 election
what i want to see and what would
actually have been worth noting
and looking at and considering is the
results of a september 2020 poll
compared to the results of a september
2016 poll
if you want to also include the 2016
results okay and then you can also
compare those not just to what people
are thinking right now
but to how people either changed their
minds
in two months in 2016 or lied to the
pollsters because we know there was a
lot of that
the polls one way or another were really
really inaccurate
in 2016. so we are being asked to
compare a poll
why do we think those are less accurate
those are more accurate now i think if
anything they're less accurate
we're being asked to compare the results
of a poll to actual election results
and not being given the actual item that
we should be comparing
to this is this is a kind of a numeracy
and it's
hard to name because it's a it's like a
category error
that this is and i fear actually i know
for sure that there are many practicing
scientists out there
who don't understand statistics well
enough to understand what things need to
be compared when they are actually
employing even basic statistical tests
and therefore you can't trust their
results because they haven't compared
the right things
sorry i'll stop you're looking at me
yeah is she ever going to stop
trouble that you're not going to use the
the obvious fruit analogy
fruit yes they've compared apples to
oranges you're supposed to say that
and i'm supposed to push back and say no
they've compared apples to apples but in
the sense
of having compared a granny smith to an
iphone 10.
yeah yeah there's a reason i don't say
they've compared apples to oranges in
front of you because because you
always do that but i will do that sort
of thing yes now this is absurd this is
this is the new york times um engaged in
the construction of
fictional narrative um using
pseudo-quantification by comparing two
things
that are not in and of themselves
comparable
they have created the impression of
a story that is going to unfold in other
words
biden is going to beat trump because if
we look at the
you know the past example it tells us
that we're actually ahead of where we
would have been
i'm speaking from their perspective but
um that we're ahead of where we would
have been in 2016 which is not the case
right um so i don't actually know i mean
i i assume
that you know we quote unquote are not
you know of course but we
here is the new york times speaking for
the democrats because the new york times
is has just stopped pretending that it's
anything but you know the voice of
of the dnc over in political space um
but
you know if i had to guess um my guess
is that those numbers would look
kind of similar for clinton
for a 2016 poll as they do for biden for
a september 2020 poll
if i had to guess not that i have access
to those data because the new york times
decided to show something that is not
actually comparable
so i want to confess something do it
i am not enumerate but i looked at this
and the first pass at this chart
succeeded in misleading me
i believed that they were making an
apples to apples comparison
the proper apples to apples comparison
and um
see now you've done it to yourself yeah
apples to apples i
i have done it to myself which is only
it's only fair
yeah um but you were you were tricked i
was
tricked because i was only dedicating
part of my mind
looking at this and just trying to
extract the data which is you know look
if you have
a newspaper that honestly reports
there's something to be said for the
ability to quickly look
at a presentation a chart or something
and derive meaning from
it and the problem is now we're in the
situation where it's like you have to
you know consider the source and what
kind of scrutiny you and skepticism you
have to
deploy in order to correct for the
biases and it's just not workable
no no it's not um so
i that's that's kind of all i have on
that yeah it wasn't even embedded in a
story
it was just a little a little graphic
that
purports to tell you something that it
actually doesn't tell you well i would
add
one thing here not so much about the
publication or this particular
duplicitous graph or chart
but the fact is if you um
increasingly we've been asked about how
to deal with
the vagaries of the moment and one of
the things that is
absolutely high maybe top of the list is
that you have to tune
into sources that you're not supposed to
be looking at
right so that you can correct for the
biases of each one
um this is a very important uh skill
under the best of circumstances and
we're not in the best of circumstances
we're in circumstances where you can't
even reconcile
perspectives from different sources but
uh the where was i headed
damn i have lost my train of thought has
anyone seen my train of thought
man that is unlike you too um that is i
suspect that is smoke talking and not
anything you've inhaled intentionally
for fun
nothing that i have inhaled
intentionally um we were talking about
the new york times the correcting for
the biases
[Music]
and i don't have it it'll be back in a
minute
all right swear it um well we this this
might be a
place to go next scientific american
has for the first time in their 175 year
history endorsed a presidential
candidate
and of course they've endorsed joe biden
and they say
um
oh you know what they've changed their
headline i believe i thought that it had
said that this was a life or
death moment but i'm not seeing that
here now so either i imagine that or
they have in fact changed their headline
um sometime over the last several hours
which is quite possible
um that's the hazard of doing this from
a live web page yeah that's right i
didn't i didn't screenshot it
um here we go so they
say a bunch of things about trump um
some of which i think are true
um the most devastating example is this
dishonest inept response to the covet 19
pandemic
which costs more than 190 000 americans
their lives by the middle of september
um i certainly inept and i think
um probably dishonest in many ways as
well i think it was the low point
um of his of his presidency uh in
in many many regards um
scientific american says he meaning
trump also has also attacked
environmental protections
medical care and the researchers and
public science agencies that helped this
country prepare for its greatest
challenges
yep i mean he's you know he's he's out
there with his
with his sword sort of slashing at
whoever irritates him in the moment i'm
sure that's happened
in all those cases that is why
scientific american continues we urge
you to vote for joe biden
who is offering fact-based plans to
protect our health our economy and the
environment
these and other proposals he has put
forth can set the country back on course
for a safer
more prosperous and wait for it more
equitable future
equity equity there it is rearing its
ugly little head
yeah yeah um i also question uh
that biden has put forth any proposals
recently well
i i agree he's not running on anything
positive there's also
no i just don't think that he's he's not
running he's not he's not the one
leading i would agree he's also um
played games with all of these claims
about
uh racial injustice and all these things
which are
for whatever reason very difficult to
demonstrate scientifically and so
this is not a simple puzzle of one of
these parties being
um uh the proper defender of science or
anything
like it right i did recover my train of
thought
if i knew i would and by the way i have
a little trick for how you do that which
is why i don't tend to get too lost on
these things
you're going to say the thing and then
you're going to give us the trick yeah
yeah i am good
so the thing was that i am hearing
from the different places that i am
tuned in some of which
are places that i find simpatico and
other places are
are ones that i find frightening in one
way or another
but i am hearing totally divergent
narratives about where we are in terms
of um who's ahead how far ahead
and you're talking about the
presidential race in particular yes in
other words
i think especially if i listen to
democrat
space there is an all-out push to sell
the idea
that biden is clobbering trump
by the numbers now mind you that was
exactly what we heard
in 2016. it it it couldn't be
more similar actually and i you know
it's it's amazing
i know you're going someplace and we
don't want you to lose this again but um
i bought it in 2016. yep i i and many
many
many people were shocked when we woke up
the day after the election
could not believe it like really thought
it was an impossibility yeah i bought it
in spite of myself
right yeah i mean yes in spite of some
some of us it was in spite of ourselves
um but uh i really believe it to be true
they're saying exactly the same stuff
why and then they're putting things like
this graphic new york times in which
they're making false comparisons and
acting like they're the right ones
well why why do we think this is any
different right and
i mean the thing is we know
in retrospect what the problem was in
2016
which was that there was noise in the
data that came from people not being
honest with those
who were taking the polls so what you
would want if you were going to do the
analysis and say oh this time the
democrats really
are ahead you would want to know why
this circumstance was less prone to that
noise
i have it the reason that uh the polls
this time are more reliable than last
time
is that the culture of fear that was
predominating in the country in 2016
has disappeared we no longer have any of
that we have achieved
the inclusive and equitable society that
the people on the fringe left have been
fighting for
in the streets with riots almost nightly
since the end of may and because of that
we have arrived
at a fully peaceful unicorn filled in
rainbow filled utopia
right now i think that's right no i
think i think you've nailed it
let's put it this way we have an added
factor on the table
right and i just people are going to
take this the wrong way
there i am not going to vote for donald
trump i'm not going to do it
but i want people to notice what
situation we're in
here in portland right we have nightly
riots
i have to confess i don't know what's
going on while we've had this thick
smoke i think it's been
reduced yeah the meaning of it i don't
know but we had something like a hundred
consecutive nights
of uh protests that were all
are almost all followed by violent riots
later in the evening
yes right we have a civil authority in
the city of portland that does not
enforce the law and is constantly
broadcasting a message
to those who are breaking the law that
they will not be treated
in a serious fashion right they're
they're being handled with kid gloves
the
governor of the state will not step in
in the absence of you know in in in the
face of the
the mayor's dereliction of duty right
that leaves
the federal government as the only line
of defense that citizens of the city of
portland
have against a violent roving riot
right that is an argument for voting for
donald trump
now because the democratically elected
and the democratically elected
democrats um in the state and the city
refuse to do their job right they are
not and you know this this is a little
bit weird to be talking about now
because we're now
uh you know over a week into a
completely different situation with the
fires and the smoke
um and so you know things have changed
and whether or not
um the rioters will have gotten out of
the habit of writing
uh when the smoke clears i don't know
although i doubt it i think they will
come back to it
i think they will too uh but it
what are we supposed to do like we're
supposed to continue to support
a total lack of leadership um which is
potentially putting
um many or all of us at actual risk
well this is this this is a sane move
let me just say i won't vote for biden
and i won't vote for trump yeah okay i'm
not going to vote for either one of them
but i do want those who are so confident
that
this time we're finally on the right
track electorally those democrats who
are
um who are beating that drum they are
missing the
fact that they are placing people like
citizens of portland in a position where
there is
a rational argument for voting for trump
where i don't think that argument
existed in 2016. that's right even more
people will not say
to their friends and family and
certainly not to pollsters
you know what this time i'm doing it yep
they will
they will lie to protect to protect the
peace within their own spheres
and we know that was happening last time
and it's
i just anecdotally we have seen we've
heard from so many people
and we see the situation that you that
you have just laid out
on the ground here and in many other
places where cities which tend to vote
blue which tend to vote democrat
there have got to be a lot of citizens
in a lot of places going
i'm not sure what my choice is here yeah
how about
the leadership the locally elected
leadership actually step up and do their
job
so i'm not forced to do something that i
don't want to do yeah
so it's a it's a very interesting
predicament and it does
uh yeah put the lie to these
these data which seem to suggest one
thing or another because
at some level people have more reason
there's more of a reason for there to be
noise in the data
that is born of people being dishonest
about what they're actually planning to
do
i don't i mean i don't i'm not sure
that's noise i think it's
hidden hidden pattern that goes the
opposite way that the polls are saying
um yeah i agree it's it's systematic
bias yeah
um okay yeah so what's the trick for
getting back to your train of thought
now i fear saying this out loud because
once you publicly have a trick for
getting back to your train of thought
when you lose your train of thought and
the trick doesn't work people are going
to think
something's up but the trick is
you put yourself you can very frequently
recover the
feeling that you had as you were
thinking
the thought like the emotional feeling
absolutely
and then you find that emotion again you
put yourself back in that emotional
mindset
and very frequently it sort of edits
down the range
of things that you might have been
thinking and
you know you sort through six or seven
thoughts and there it is that's so good
it's like it's an analogy
it's it's emotion dependent memory
analogized i would say to state
dependent learning that is exactly what
it is and it's actually
um you know i've talked about state
dependent learning
having uh important relationship to
music and emotion
and this is this is where that thought
came from is that these things are
coded there's basically a dewey decimal
system of
you know there's an emotional catalog so
that you're not constantly searching the
sum total of all the things you might
um say or think you're only searching
the relevant part
so maybe maybe you don't want to go here
but i guess i'm surprised uh that you
can
find enough nuance in your emotional
state from one moment to another
especially when we're like live
streaming here
that you can identify oh this was like
it was like two minutes ago
i know what i was feeling then as
opposed to the minute either side of it
like how that's that's the level of
specificity that i would
i don't know how i would accomplish that
um i cannot say how easy it will be for
others it's possible that this is
really easy for everyone once you
realize to try it
it's possible that it's one of these
things you know like
you know you know i'm weirdly good at
spotting
a particular voice and placing it yeah
if some
if some voice is used in a commercial i
can very often figure out who you are
um so it might be one of those you know
weird skills
i sort of suspect it's not for some
reason
i think probably because the emotion is
sort of a bigger category
right there's some general emotion that
you have towards some specific story
and so that emotion holds all of the
things that you think in its context and
it is therefore slower to dissipate
because as you lose the particular
thread you're still in the same
landscape
so you can very often if you realize
you've lost your train of thought you
can find
well how do i feel i don't know why i
feel that way because i don't know what
i was thinking but
i still do feel that way and then you
can sort of put yourself back there
and i guess maybe another thing that's
surprising me to me about this then
is that you don't just feel like oh [ __ ]
i forgot i was thinking
like why how is it that you can find
anything through the
like low grade but something of a panic
response like ah
it's gone well actually you know it's
funny there's an analogy for this
and it connects a little bit to my
conversation that i had with greg
gutfeld on his podcast
um where he talked about our podcast so
this is now totally tangled but
we were talking about lucid dreams and
one of the things about lucid dreams
which i learned
through some stuff that the stanford
research
sleep research center had put out on
lucid dreams yeah
was that the problem many people have
the beginnings of lucid dreams but the
problem is that the
discovery that you're dreaming is so
jarring that it wakes you right up
right and you have to like not not look
at it
right you have to calm yourself you have
to calm yourself to
the discovery that you're dreaming so
you don't startle yourself awake and
that's sort of how you
get through it and this is the same
thing you have to not panic over the
fact that you have
lost your train of thought um admittedly
harder when you're
streaming to a live audience but right
nonetheless you have to not panic over
it and
actually as you get better at it you
develop confidence that you can get back
to your thought if you work at it um
which also makes you calmer
ah right so uh the more you do it the
better you get
yep there's there's a positive practice
element too yeah
excellent um
well let's see um i definitely do want
to talk about
uh this this snake at some point uh i
don't know if you
want to speak about this uh
this paper that uh we were looking at
sure you want to do that and speak about
this paper so actually
there are two things so i don't know if
you want to go to the zero hedge article
or
yeah you might as well let's get
ourselves in trouble with all of the
people who
uh consider zero hedge problematic okay
zacho all right so here we have
zero hedges uh report on
this preprint that emerged
um yeah i'm not sure it even counts as a
pre-print right
oh it's because it's not on a pre-print
server yeah yeah it's so what is this
document and i must tell you
one we can also show the document yeah
you want to show the document i sent you
a pdf
i've got it here hold on
oh maybe i know
yep yeah we do down here yeah so you
need to scroll up
out here yeah that's not going to be
hold on zach
here yeah
so brett you for people listening yeah
so for people listening what we've got
is a paper here the title of the paper
is
unusual features of the sars cove ii
genome suggesting sophisticated
laboratory modification
rather than natural evolution and
delineation of its probable
synthetic route the lead author
is yan now i must say i don't know yan
she's been in this landscape
for um months now
and the chinese virologist who had been
working and living in hong kong who left
hong kong
um without the authorities in her home
country wanting her to presumably in
april of this year i think
right so i have trepidation about her
work in part because
it is traveling outside of
the realms that might allow you to you
know as you point out not a pre-print
right not on a pre-print server now i'm
not sure why i'm
more troubled by a a paper put out
outside of a pre-print server given that
the pre-print servers
have requirements about credentials um
and that that can be used to bar certain
things but nonetheless
i mean the fact is that the regardless
of
who's in premature is on this uh with
regard to the organization
uh that is that is named here we've got
what is it for four phds who've written
a paper that is very well researched
actually if you can just put that down
so i can read the screen here um here we
go
just second paragraph of the
introduction as a coronavirus sars cove
two different significantly from other
respiratory and or zoonotic viruses
it attacks multiple organs it is capable
of undergoing a long period of
asymptomatic infection
it is highly transmissible and
significantly lethal in high-risk
populations
it is well adapted to humans it's the
very start of its emergence
it is highly efficient in binding the
human ace2 receptor
the affinity of which is greater than
that associated with the ace2 of any
other potential host
and it goes on and on and on so a this
fits with a number of things that we
talked about early in our live streams
and that you talked about with yuri
deegan tegan um in the podcast that you
did with him
uh and you know they've just they also a
big part of their argument here is
that there's been active censorship by
the scientific community
and by the journals um
presumably at least potentially also
therefore by the pre-print servers
themselves
um against publishing anything that
suggests uh
a lab origin for the virus right and you
know and
we did this for like 18 episodes running
back in our first 18 or so episodes but
um you know lab origin is not the same
thing as bioweapon we're talking about
um you know to say lab origin does not
specify whether or not you're talking
about
an inadvertent escape um on one end to
an intentional release of an intentional
bioweapon on the other or anything in
between
and you know really most of these
analyses are imagining it's some sort of
like oh my god this is being developed
and it escaped and no one ever meant it
to but really nothing about
how it got out into the world is part of
the analysis around
does it or does not does it not have a
lab origin i guess the other thing is
as people who've been watching for a
long time will understand
that lab origin doesn't mean created
from scratch in the lab
it means you know borrowed
from other viruses and um
made into a chimera slash engineered
primarily from parts that's one of the
things it means composited
from natural sources but the other thing
that it means which has very ominous
implications here
is what's called serial passage
experiments basically
use selection in the lab artificial
selection
to imbue viruses with capacities that
they wouldn't
otherwise have and so again don't know
what to make
of this paper though it looks to be very
well researched
but the paper is putting together some
of the things that we did talk about
early on about
how much of the frightening part of this
virus
you know it's diversity of organs that
it attacks right
its ability to transmit between human
beings
how many of these features are actually
the result
of a guided evolutionary process in a
lab
coupled with a compositing which could
be
of totally honorable origin in other
words people who wish to study a virus
that was dangerous to humans may have
created a virus that was unusually
dangerous to humans
and then it got out through an accident
so that's the most likely scenario as
far as i'm concerned
and we are now beginning to see analyses
that
strongly reflect this so at a different
level
zach i would ask you to put up the uh
the alina
chan article from boston from the
okay here it is
right so here what we have is
a profile of somebody i've been
following online
since boy i don't know
march something like that
alina chan who is a
young researcher a problem solver
who became suspicious of the origin
story
of sars cove ii on the basis of many
things primary among them is something
else you will have heard us discuss here
many times
which is the fact that this virus hit
the ground
running and was already extremely well
adapted to infect human beings rather
than well that's in that list
that i read from here in this in this
paper right and so
in any case um this article is written
for
lay audience it's very accessible i
highly recommend it
and it does a number of things one it
tells
told me a lot of things i didn't know
about dr chan
one of them that i'm particularly
intrigued by
is that her story as a scientist
is not a typical one of her having been
a brilliant student and
this and that she is somebody who didn't
love school
always bridled against its uh its
constraints
and um has in spite of those things
emerged
as a um a brilliant virologist
who has spotted all the things that were
wrong about the story
of sars kovetu and investigated them and
has established
many of these claims on a very rigorous
basis falsified for example the
claim about pangolins and the source of
the spike protein
so anyway i would just recommend this
article to people we will post a link to
it
um but uh i i don't know maybe uh maybe
dr chan will come on the dark horse
podcast at some point because she seems
like a true dark horse
that would be great yep all right is it
snake time
yes well it's always snack time
an hour okay we'll finish with snakes
how about that or one snake really
so um this is a report it's also from
the new york times
i don't know maybe they got this one
right i can a person can hope
um a 62 year old ball python at the st
louis
zoo uh here we go zach if you want to
put that up
uh a 62 year old python at the st louis
zoo
who has not had access to a male for at
least 15 years
has laid seven eggs and
um not only has she not had access to a
male for at least 15 years
um she's already a couple of decades
past her sell by date
apparently usually they don't live that
long but these eggs are
at least some of them are alive ah
there were seven of them two of them
died two of them
were um i think killed for research
purposes
and three of them as of as of right now
are still alive and have not there
um let's see how do they they end the
article with they are not
counting their snakes before they're
hatched um so there's three that are
still
um potentially going to hatch killed no
mistake with all of the scanning
technology
it's hard for me to imagine that there
was any justification of that and i
could i'm not actually positive that's
what happened to the two of them because
it's a you know it's written for a lay
audience
i couldn't quite tell but i think i
think that they um they basically
um collected the eggs for research
purposes and
in so doing uh killed whatever embryos
um
might have been developing inside um but
there are three still out there
but this i mean this just raises so many
interesting questions
doesn't it um we have for instance let's
just let's just start with okay
she hasn't seen a male in 15 years could
she have stored sperm for that long
there are very long storm storm sporage
that's not
that's not a thing that's not a thing um
sperm storage
uh things that organisms do
uh usually it's not years and years and
years but it certainly is
known um in ants it is in ants yeah
i said i said it yeah it's not it's not
as common in vertebrates yeah i think
um you know the example that i think of
um with regard to storage
um actually there's just a whole lot of
ways to get around the problem of
you want to reproduce but you're not
sure you're going to be able to find a
mate at the right moment so
like we've all been there oh my god
we'll have to talk about that yeah this
is awkward yeah um
like wolverines i'm not sure wolverines
do sperm storage or do they just do
delayed implantation
yeah so they actually they they bring
sperm and egg together
and then they have they basically put
put that zygote
into stasis um throughout
much of the fall and part of the winter
while the wolverines are in
um basically in sleep for the winter and
then they
and then only at the point that the
seasonality is
looking right uh does the zygote get
implanted in the uterine lining and
start to develop um so that's you know
that's one way
that uh reproduction can be delayed um
but actual just storing of sperm to be
used at some later point
is um is common in ants and i didn't
look at
a lot of a lot of other species that's
right you know a lot of mammals a lot of
bats
have a you know and these periods of
storage just
allow you to break the connection
between the mating period
and the point at which offspring are
born and there are lots of different
versions of it where
the uh you know the place where the
pause happens in the reproductive cycle
can be moved along to different spots no
and you know and just
because i want to talk about wolverines
for a moment more
um the example there is that because
they live in a cold habitat and
basically need to hibernate in order to
make it through the winter uh you're not
doing a lot of courtship while you're
hibernating it's
just i'm sorry i'm about to reveal
my ignorance i thought
because wolverine specialized on large
carcasses i thought they weren't
hibernating have i misunderstood
wolverine behavior
you know i didn't i should have i should
have looked up our our former student
alice's work on this before i started
talking about wolverines um it's
possible i've misremembered
the hibernation thing but i think i
think not
um and precisely the argument for pause
is that
they they basically they do their meet
and greet and court chip
and sexual reproduction um in the fall
when they actually are
going around sourcing food and then once
they're in their dens
and it's and the timing is right such
that a baby could be born as spring was
happening
uh that's when implantation occurs but
um but we'll definitely correct that if
if i'm wrong about that so if you're a
wolverine and we've gotten this wrong
don't panic we will fix the record
so it correctly reflects dallas if
you're watching which i know you have
been at some point in the past um
definitely correct me if i've got it
wrong which i might be yeah
um but okay so sperm storage for over 15
years
in a ball python where that's never been
noticed before
probably not possible but probably not
so i would say chances are very very
very low because
even if sperm storage were a thing there
is
it's hard to imagine an ecological
circumstance that would require that
duration of sperm storage therefore yes
it's unlikely to work
zoo is a novel environment for ball
pythons yes
yes very much so um so
probably it's facultative
parthenogenesis that's a couple of words
put together that sound like biospeed
because they are but facultative being
the
um counterpoint to obligate so if
something is obligated it always happens
100 of the time so humans are obligately
sexually reproducing
um and this bulb these ball pythons
apparently
are facultatively usually sexually
producing but facultatively
parthenogenetic meaning that they can
probably
self themselves probably not cloning but
it's possible but probably selfing
um and let's go back to that because i
think we
there's some fun stuff to talk about
there but um another interesting thing
is that
all snakes have long been understood to
have genetic sex determination
that they have sex chromosomes just as
mammals do although it's a separate
evolution of sex chromosomes
and um just like birds do in fact which
is again a separate evolution of sex
chromosomes from mammals
um birds have a zw system not an xy
system
so in birds and mammals um
everyone probably watching or listening
to this will know this but maybe not in
these terms
that female mammals are xx
and because the two x's are the same
chromosome looking chromosome that's
called homo comedic same
gamete and males who are xy mammals
are heterogametic different gametes at
that in the case of humans 23rd
chromosome position and that's true for
all mammals except the monotremes which
are just
weird and they've got like nine pairs of
sex chromosomes and let's not talk about
them at the moment that's the duckbill
platypus and the two echidnas
so they're bizarre but all of the the
marsupials and the placental mammals
that's
us um have this xy system and
birds have a different evolution of
chromosomal sex determination
uh which for just reasons of not
confusing them is called the zw system
in which it's the females
who are heterogeneic so females are z-w
and the males are homogeneic and i
actually don't remember i think i think
it's cz i don't remember if we call them
zz or ww
i just don't know um and that that
actually
makes for some interesting predictions
about behavior that we won't go into
here but are fascinating
and for a long time it was thought that
all snakes
had like birds but separately evolved a
zw chromosomal sex determination system
but a recent paper in 2017
finds that at least two lineages within
the boads a python and a boa not the
ball python but a different species of
python
have an xy system and that the python
and the bow are themselves independently
evolved so we've got
all these different evolutions of sex
chromosomes within
snakes at least three and probably more
all right so
am i correct in recalling that it is a
python there's one snake lineage that
has
vestigial limbs it's
basil the the bowids okay and pythons
are boweds as boaz so this is weird
somewhere
within the bowed lineage you have an
xy system right apparently
all right now this this raises so many
questions that we cannot
trouble our darkhorse audience with
because they're not going to want to go
into the weeds with us but some of them
do
here's the question yeah which thing
switched
while you talk zach you can just show
this this so that people can look if
they want to
yeah discovery of x so okay i am
now frustrated assuming they don't sort
this out i'm frustrated with our
colleagues for having defined this as an
xy system oh i agree
and calling calling what's happening all
the rest of the snakes is ew says cw
says no it's wrong
because it's not the same every separate
evolution of this should have its own
set of letters 100
talk about it and you know you could
come up with a convention so you knew
which was
uh which but yeah um but here's the
question
two so if you have snakes
embedded within the boad lineage who
have an xy system
when the rest of snakes have a zw system
if this is a reversal then the question
is which thing
reversed was it the sex did the sex flip
yeah that is to say the phenomenology of
the sex did it
change which critter it was appended to
or
did the chromosomal system switch
or and i think this is more likely given
what we see if we if we sort of map sex
determination systems onto all of
vertebrates are all of tetrapods which
is the
vertebrates that have come onto land
that include the amphibians reptiles
birds and mammals
um you actually see you know quite
clearly that environmental sex
determination is basal
right that you have systems and you know
many people will be familiar with the
idea that there are some turtles for
instance
where if you if your egg develops hot
you you end up
female and if it develops cold you end
up male um
and then there's some where intermediate
ones are female i
can't remember they're they're all all
three of the possible systems are out
there in terms of environmental sex
determination which almost always means
temperature sex determination yep that
only works of course
for um organisms that lay eggs a
viviparous organism that had temperature
sex determination right
is not going to work because the
mother's body temperature can't
can't be totally different for different
sex broods that's just not how
anatomy and physiology works if you did
it you'd end up with broods that were
all
the same sex right but then you'd have
to you know unless
unless there was a whole part of the
population that was at one temperature
all the time and
only produced female like it just it
does it doesn't quite track but anyway
environmental sex determination is basal
and genetic sex determination seems to
evolve multiple multiple times within
the tetrapod lineage
and so more light more than more likely
than some snakes going from a zy to an
xy system directly
they went back to not having sex
chromosomes or not having them code for
sex
yeah and then evolved or you know
switched them while they weren't coding
for sex into the opposite
the opposite thing which raises a really
interesting question about what it is
that causes an environmentally
sex-determined creature to go
chromosomal
etc but i think you don't want to get me
started on that
no i don't um forgive me i think you
have buried the lead slightly with
respect to
uh our audience and what they're going
to think faculty apartheid
there you go right that's that's where
we're going right here okay good i mean
go go for it that's that's that's the
big thing
um but i just didn't want to not talk
about the other stuff well okay
so what i would want us to say is
that this is a place where the failure
of imagination amongst biologists the
over-generalization from
our own circumstance has i believe
caused us to miss the boat and we are
now very predictably getting schooled by
nature
on the following point as far as we know
we don't have a mammalian example
um except jesus christ of
um of parthenogenesis in a mammal
am i right that that's still true
parthenogenesis being reproduction of a
female with no
input from a male right so
this seems weird to us that anything
does this that any
uh animal does this or any vertebrate at
least
but if you think about the puzzle of
how creatures find new places to do
their creature thing how we get a
species you know if you have
one species of python over here and then
you have a closely related species
of python over there that eat something
different and behave slightly
differently but anyway they're related
but they ended up in two different
places what happened
well in general a creature
will have gotten lost or you know i
don't know some predatory bird could
pick up a python and accidentally drop
it as it was carrying it to its nest in
some new place
and this will happen a lot and in
general
the animal that's dropped won't be able
to reproduce because there's only one of
them
and in the absence of a mate it will
maybe get by maybe not but it will die
it will be the end of its lineage
if it is capable of reproducing
then it could be an evolutionary winner
of like an
unimaginably great type which is the
founder of a new population
so the question is is there a
contingency plan
built into creatures for those
circumstances in which they find
themselves in a habitat that's great
but for the absence of a mate now if
you're a mammal
you might get blown off course for your
bat you might get blown off course
pregnant and you might find yourself
someplace with a couple of offspring and
maybe they're
the right sex to reproduce and you know
yes that's incest but nonetheless it
might still result in the
birth of a new population but
even easier if you physiologically are
built for it is the production of
offspring
that would be triggered by extreme
loneliness
right that the loneliness of a creature
would be an indication that there's
nobody else of the right kind around
and at some point loneliness would be
sufficient to trigger the production
of either clonal or self-fertilized
eggs which could then pending various
questions like do they have the right
chromosomal complement that you get
multiple sexes out of the brood um that
could then
found a new population that should have
happened many times but the problem is
if you don't expect it because you're
not doing the evolutionary theory very
well
then you don't notice the fact that this
is probably happening with some
regularity
even in your zoos you have to pay very
close attention in order to know
that animal has not had access to
another animal of its kind a closely
related species with it which it might
hybridize
right you have to know that really well
and frankly
how many times has some zookeeper who
does know it really well
said to the higher-ups at the zoo i
don't know where these
eggs came from but that animal hasn't
had a mate and the higher up at the zoo
is probably oh you must have messed up
whatever right yeah so now we are in
this era where we are discovering that
lots of creatures it turns out
produce offspring without reproducing
when we isolate them
which undoubtedly is revealing that this
is a very common evolutionary mechanism
now
we've we've got several examples now
from the mates some
some snakes some komodo dragons yep um
and we've got sharks you've seen it in
sharks yep um
birds have you seen a bird yet not yet
no i don't i
i don't think that's going to happen
i don't think it's going to happen yeah
i don't i think mammals and birds
are not going to it's not going to have
happened
and not that it's not going to start to
happen but i think i don't think
we're missing that why let's see um
mammals and birds are not each of their
closest relatives
their most recent common ancestor is the
same as their ancestor with
this python um which was a long time ago
at the origin of
tetrapod no it wasn't the origin of
tetrapods but it was a long time ago
origin of reptiles um some
combination of their endothermy
and their um high
heart rate the the convergence of
cardiac anatomy and endothermic and
um brain size and
i can't quite put it all together but i
actually i just don't
think that mammals or birds are going to
end up with faculty of parthenogenesis
and i want to think more on exactly why
yeah
i i don't think so i don't see the
obstacle though the fact that we haven't
seen it in either of these two
clades yet um suggests you may be right
for reasons like
i can't figure out i would say more
likely in birds though
because of the zw system right because a
bird female you need to have an
egg-laying creature in order to pull
this off
right a male mammal can't produce
parthenogenic
offspring so a female has to do it and a
female mammal
at least a marsupial or
a placental would produce
female offspring because she doesn't
have a y chromosome to throw at the
problem
if she produces female offspring then
you get a line of females which is not
necessarily capable of switching back
into a sexual mode
on the other hand a bird with zw could
produce
a brood of eggs if she selfed rather
than cloned she could produce
a brood of eggs that was partially
female and partially male and therefore
the distinction being
there are many many mechanisms for which
you can get there but selfing is
basically putting two of your own
gametes together
uh to produce a zygote as opposed to
cloning
and so with cellphone you end up with a
reduction in the
um in genetic diversity genetic
diversity yeah it
sounds like the right word but um you
end up with more homogeneity
um across loci um with selfing but
you could get um a z gamete and a w
gamete coming together or a z gamut and
a z gambit coming together
even if you yourself um rzw
whereas if you're only xx you keep where
would you get the y gamete
so you wouldn't be able to produce a
male one last thing to your point about
um
you know the komodo dragon that um
has swum across to a new island and
found itself unable to get back because
of currents
and is she is all alone um
is that um this strategy
of um of using extreme loneliness to
prompt a reproductive event
only works for half of the organisms of
course right and
males no matter how lonely cannot end up
selfing or cloning their way
into uh into reproducing and
you know this seems like you know maybe
i'm just being mean or maybe this is a
small point but this is actually
the fundamental thing that is why i
and many others are just so adamant
about you know what male is real and
female is real and no amount of
pretending is going to make it any
different because it is about the
gametes
and female is to have a large incessal
gamete and male is to have a
small and motile gamete and what makes
that gamete large in the case of a
female
and that gamut being an egg it's all the
cytoplasm it's all the cellular
machinery of life that is necessary
to actually make a cell and so you put
two sperm together
you're just gonna get something zippy
that can't actually persist for very
long
can't and can't divide and grow it just
doesn't have
the mitochondria and the just the
ribosomes it doesn't have all the stuff
it needs
so half of half of your supremely lonely
squamates say snakes and lizards that
end up alone on an island are still out
of luck
and half of them if they're male and
half of them if they're female may
actually be able to
um to turn that into a reproductive wind
so your your biological essentialism on
this point is liable to get you accused
of being a transphobe and i should say
that's happened before
i will stand by you because i am not
transphobophobic
um i am trans activist phobic
increasingly
yeah watching how they have uh treated
jk rowling and others
um but in any case uh yeah is there more
to say about
um parkland genesis i mean yes i
obviously i could go on forever but we
should stop all right yes maybe we've
reached that point okay
so we will return in 15 minutes
to do our q and a um
is there anything we should say here
consider joining us on our patreons um
either of them you can get access to
discord server
online you can also get access to our
once a month
uh private live q and a that we do on
the last sunday of the month
and uh you also will have access to the
past ones that we
leave up and the clips channel also has
clips from past episodes and
anything else i know there is uh you
know like subscribe
comment circulate yeah um
so we'll be answering your super chat
questions in the next hour
all right be well
you